i would drink these drinks called um
vodka mud shakes which are like
it's like vodka and chocolate milk i
guess pre-mix and it is um
it's not good
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who once pitched an actual fit
when her parents wouldn't drive on icy
snow-covered roads to take her to her
boyfriend's house on a snow day elise
morales
and with us today we have such
a funny friend he's our second ever
international guest he's a comedian and
co-host of the worst idea of all time
podcast you've seen him on comedy
central and at the jeff's for last
festival in montreal but before
all of that he was a graduate of christ
college it's guy montgomery oh thank you
so much what a delight to be here
wow you are our second international
guest
well who did you book before me
uh we we had a guest from haiti so i
think it's gonna be really different
actually
yeah i feel like they are probably quite
different schooling experiences
so right off the bat people usually
start by telling us
their mascot did your school have a
mascot
no no i school spirit in new zealand is
very different and at the
the school i went to uh you know
different again our mascot
with hindsight would probably be the
student body of about 500
white boys
one of the scariest mascots a school
could possibly have
yeah actually that's terrifying like why
do you even need
um a panther or whatever
to represent you when that is what you
have in your corner
yeah uh no i was always jealous of you
know the idea of um
those sort of outfits that a cheerleader
or a gymnast would wear on the
sidelines of uh sports games to
encourage everyone to barrack we didn't
use that word either to barrack for your
team
but our own devices
did you guys you guys just didn't do the
school spirit thing at all
you were focused on the holy spirit uh
yeah the the school is it's anger it is
it's technically anglican like that's
one of the uh that's what they like to
say
uh but yeah there's like it's really
there's no similarities in terms of like
there's no unifying um
oh we played sports and whatnot and
you're supposed to support your school
but there's just we we lack some of the
pageantry
and the uh the general showmanship of
america
to my chagrin at the time i was furious
i felt like i was in the wrong
school in the wrong country you know
i've come home
this kaleidoscope of the us schooling
experience or like i'd
race home to watch keenan and kell or i
hey or like hey all sorts of mostly
nickelodeon shows yeah
well hey arnold yeah they had like
lockers like they were supposed to be in
fourth grade on hey arnold but like
they were in high school kind of but
yeah yeah but i mean that
i didn't know i couldn't fact-check any
of this i was just like this is what
it's like
everyone's in mufti we call it mufti do
you have that word
what what is that so musty day it was a
day where you got to um wear your
free dress i think you call it oh okay
so where you get to like wear your
regular clothes yeah yeah so i
from the ages from the age of five to 18
i would go to school
button down white shirt tie
blazer uh my little shorts socks
long socks with gutters black shoes
oh so you had like a full little outfit
yeah yeah yeah i was um you know i was
very i would be
have been very desirable to any anyone
lurking in the bushes in the park on the
way to school we were dressed up to the
nines
it is like i do the thing that comes to
mind when you describe that
to me is dudley dursley getting his
little outfit
in harry potter like when his cousin
gets his um
his like little i don't know he gets a
little outfit
yeah yeah it's still here we go we got a
little outfit and um
it's it's it was i i hated it i didn't
hate it like i just accepted it because
i was five and i was like well this is
just what you've got to wear to go to
school i don't know any better until you
start watching tv
but tv we were not really allowed to
watch tv my folks were like no
no you don't need that and so you know
you get half an hour a week
on weekdays and then you get cartoons in
the weekend or whatever
but it wasn't until i started seeing you
know other versions of school
i was like this is totally bogus it's
just it's so much to do
for 13 years of your life to have to be
putting on all this formal wear
i learned to tie a tie at five it's it's
it's insane it's not necessary it's it
is absolutely not necessary
i agree yeah it's it's interesting
is are so are uniforms basically the
norm
the schools were like independent we
call them all private schools in new
zealand so they were like
they're for um flash or you know flash
kids or they're meant to be
you need you know um and they're meant
to sort of
churn you out to join the new zealand
workforce as an upstanding citizen who
understands beautiful
red sheets and um you know the law
or something yeah they teach you how to
wear your little suit so you can wear
the big suit after yeah
yeah but you know this rebellious fellow
i can't stand i feel shackled in a suit
you know i like that
i like to wear my muffin whenever i can
yeah so mufti day was like a day where
you got to wear whatever you want
and you'd um you'd have to it was like a
gold coin donation so like one or two
dollars
and uh the worst feeling would be
because you know you get so
little opportunity to express yourself
through your clothes
the worst would be you'd forget muffy
day and you'd show up and the like the
most humiliating experience is being in
your school uniform when everyone else
was wearing whatever the hell was
oh no yeah that is actually horrible
did that was that like there was always
someone who forgot
there was always there was always
someone and everyone like usually
everyone would have had a turn to do it
if you were lucky
you could try and you know um call in
some sort of hero favor from a parent or
a
sibling to russians and mufti clothes
but they wouldn't even know how to
choose the best
outfit yeah exactly like the the
opportunity
squandered because he wanted to pick
like your
look so let's say it's muffy day
what is teen guy wearing to school
i'm wearing um a pair of quick silver
board shorts
cut very neatly just below the knee
and the way you know that they're
quicksilver is quicksilver have printed
the biggest possible clip silver logo
on one of the legs so that no one is
mistaking
what brand of board shorts these are
like i was so obsessed with the idea of
this soup i watched blue crush
and was like surfing it's surfing for me
yeah
and so you crash a seminal text
how could you watch blue crush and not
think
it's surfing for me like like you at
least have to walk away
from that movie in that day dedicated to
surfing
i couldn't agree more a friend and i got
into serving for two weeks after that
but it was um
it's harder than it looks in the movie
and like christchurch had a beach but
it's not
yeah yeah we didn't we it didn't really
take off yeah i was gonna ask
are you near a surfing
uh so christchurch has it's um
it's got a fantastic geographical
position it's on the coast on the east
coast of the south island of new zealand
uh and it's not quite equidistant but
it's like you've got the beach
if you go if you drive out east you've
got the beach and to the west you've got
uh mountain ranges so you could it's
like the it's almost
like the the town on rocket power do you
remember rocket power
oh do i remember
how can you look at me and not see that
i was influenced so deeply by reggie
rocket yeah
i see it and hear it now so
like you could you could go skiing and
you could go surf and if you really
wanted to but you'd have to work pretty
hard you could do both on the same day
which is what always blew my mind on
rocket powers like how these kids fit so
much in
they they really did they were
masters of all extreme sports
yeah even the squared yeah yeah which
was admirable for his
his new status as a member of the how to
long village
because he was too fat to use him
while that while the surfing didn't take
off my fandom of surf wear
was overwhelming and um to the point
that
you know if the 13 year old or whatever
version of me who was wearing those
quicksilver board shorts knew that as an
adult
i would have the option to dress myself
exclusively in quicksilver
and somehow wound up not doing that it
would be incomprehensible
yeah um but so yeah out of the
quicksilver i'd have like the
quicksilver board shorts
i'd have on uh like a billabong
a grey billabong t-shirt great did you
get billabong over there oh yeah
we got we have all the same ones all the
stuff that you're describing
is like the tip like you're like a
pacsun guy did you have
the store pacsun pacific sun
so all of the things that you are
describing
there's like a very iconic teen mall
store called pacsun where if one was
interest if one watched blue crush and
said
my life is now dedicated to surf style
you would
shop at paxton and they had billabong
and quicksilver
yeah and i mean other places had vans
but like
yeah all that stuff was there the topic
would be i would wear here
but like one of those metal link uh
not like a puka shell necklace but like
one of those middle link ones that goes
around that look it's a it's a bad it
was a bad look then it is a
there's a bad look now it's scary it was
like a choke
or a metal choker kind of it's like
it's like a 13 year old step down from a
neck tattoo
it's sort of like you know i am also you
know don't be deceived by the
soft green in the board shorts i'm rough
and tumble so we
really did have like i mean
you had a style that you wanted to
express so it probably did it
did suck to have to wear the little
outfit because i imagine some boys who
had like
there are some teenage boys who have no
style and they don't care and like
someone picking out their outfit for
them every day is whatever but we
you wanted to express your you yeah yeah
but it's it wasn't like it wasn't led by
any sense of individuality or genuine
desire it was just like
it was driven by you know we didn't have
algorithms back then
but i was piecing together what i
thought were the coolest things in the
world which were
visible brands and like anything that
sort of meant
i was um i would blend in with
not the largest group but like the group
of people with whom i like the best like
i l you know i
i i just wanted to feel and look cool
and in a way
don't we all yeah still to this day
yeah yeah that never changes you just
kind of recalculate
what looking cool actually i know but
i i think back to that time i guess i
wouldn't change too i had these um these
are
my they're like my the beacon of like
the coolest thing i had was these um
nike
like f leisurewear sunglasses that had
pop-out lenses the frames you could pop
out the lens and i had two sets of
lenses one which is like your sort of
uh plain black they were like silver
frames with a yellow nike tick on the
side there one were playing black but i
also these
are translucent or transparent like
see-through orange
lenses that i'd put in all the time when
i was when i was rocking those i was
like
oh sorry i'm cool now
okay so socially teen
guy where does he like fall w what's his
crew
at school what would you do what would
you think your
rap was apart from cool surf guy
yeah yeah i i i think
i wasn't uh especially cool
but i was also not especially uncool i
was sort of like
i was i was middle of the road uh
friendly with most people i had a very
close group of friends who
the christ college was separated into
like a housing system
not unlike harry potter but instead of
four houses
there were ten houses and instead of a
transphobic author
there was some sort of homophobic
headmaster
[Laughter]
i had like so i was in a house called
cough house all the houses were named
after um
old guys old alumni
old white guys who came to new zealand
like this place one of their big selling
points is that the schools
i was founded in 1850 and like the
treaty of waitangi which is essentially
our founding document to say that
new zealand got colonized uh was
was signed in 1840 and so this school is
like almost as
old as the uh colonel as you know as the
invaded country itself yes
as that whole thing yeah yeah and so
that all of the houses there were ten
houses there were four
boarding houses and six day boy houses
and i was in courthouse and i was lucky
enough to be
to wind up in a house with um four of
my four or four guys who who were some
of them already were but like
we became uh unbelievably close-knit
thick as
thieves yeah i believe the dickensian
turn of phrases
and uh we were like pretty happy in our
own little silo we'd sort of you know
cross over and interact with the um
other others other guys but like yeah
inside of ourselves we were pretty happy
we weren't we weren't in the best sports
teams and we weren't
kissing all the uh the prettiest girls
at the parties in the weekend
but we were um having a lot of laughs
having a lot of fun making a lot of
memories
anyway it was the friends you made along
the way yeah yeah
okay so what like amount uh
i always am interested in this when i'm
talking to people who went to
like high school elsewhere were you guys
allowed to drink
no okay uh the the legal drinking age in
new zealand is 18
okay so legally
no and obviously the school is a
the the school's motto is um
which is latin a dead language
and it means uh good traditions to be
well maintained so the school was very
precious about
you know how you represent the school
you'd always get told you know
like the school's kind of in the
christchurch cbd and when you go out
like you
you'd have to get a leave slip to leave
the school campus at lunch time to go
and get food or whatever and
whenever you do that they'd always be
like uh yeah you know when you're
wearing that uniform
you're not just representing yourself
you're representing the school
and you'll be like yeah okay [ __ ] old
man you
yeah it's cool all right yeah like gonna
pay two dollars
for something like make me wear this
yeah yeah
and so you weren't allowed to drink like
some of the um
there was a there was a or at least in
my interpretation of the pecking order
of
coolness at school some of the cooler
kids would um
like they might sneak off to smoke weed
or or have a drink at lunchtime but to
me that was beyond the pale of
naughtiness that was terrifying
like i was convinced that as soon as you
did that you'd get caught
and um i i lived in fear i
to this day i i like nothing worse than
getting in trouble like i get as soon as
i get a knot in my stomach and it's like
it's you know
you're you immediately are just flipping
through the rolodex of everything that
you've done wrong in the last day week
month yeah like your entire life you're
like what are they nailing me for right
now
i'm like it's it's not great but i'm
like all talk and then as soon as i
actually get in trouble
i'm crying immediately
and this was a problem in high school
because i would like argue with my
teachers and then they would be like
you're in trouble and i would just like
collapse on the ground yeah yeah and
i didn't really i understood that lying
existed as a concept but not as it
applied to me like if
if they were you know bailing me out for
something and i was guilty
there was no hope for me or any of my
cohorts to get away with it was like
yeah
yeah you you go you got us yeah
oh i admitted to everything immediately
i was like the
worst person to get in trouble with
caved a cave immediately i can't handle
the pressure of getting in trouble
oh it's such a it's just such a um
yeah it's it's a bad fit and i think
it's different for different people but
it was like drilled into me i was a very
obedient
differential child like it didn't occur
to me that teachers were fallible
until probably my last year of high
school or
you know which is late it's too late
like there were teams i didn't like but
i would still
sort of defer to their authority
somewhat there was a guy and
and we called it the grades it's like
they're the same but we we talked
differently about in fourth form which
is your second year of high school so i
would have been
13 or 14 i took um speech and drama
classes
and uh the the chemistry teacher was
this guy called mr harwood who with
hindsight
probably was suffering from several
outstanding brain injuries from a
semi-professional rugby career
and he was okay and moved tremendously
slowly and he did not have a lot of
respect for the performing arts
and when i would say i can't i'll be in
chemistry today i've got to go to speech
and drama
you'd say no no you're like you can only
leave if you've got a music list and you
can't leave
for speech and drama and it sort of
started this like
i didn't like you know i didn't like the
guy but i still was like okay well if he
says i can't leave i can't i can't leave
and so
i would like put um i used to put
universal indicator and all the
hydrochloric acids in the
in the classroom so they'd all go red
you couldn't do experiments with them
and it was like you know that was my
my vengeance and then that's a really
good
prank though that's really like that's
well thought out
well yeah you're working at a huge
advantage if the teacher is suffering
from a lifetime of concussions and
literally it's true
15 minutes to turn around but i would do
that yeah he had ctes
yeah yeah and then through all this
i was like i just did not apply myself
or care about chemistry and i remember i
got um
we're just an exam at the end of you
know
i think in fourth form where science
would be split into
terms so there are four terms in a year
and they'd be like one of them would be
chemistry one of them would be physics
one of them would be biology and one of
them would be general and with an
item if you like one of them you could
study them in an applied sense the next
year or whatever
but i got um i remember doing the
chemistry test and being like oh i'm out
of my depth and writing a letter on the
last
you know there was sort of some equation
based sciences then there was an essay
one and i remember writing like
i remember being taught this stuff i
i you know sorry but this ain't me and i
got 25
which was a score so low and i think
that
mr harwood and the school found the
letter
was pretty you know politely written
letter so disrespectful that i got
something called um
saturday night detention oh no
i had to go back to the school on
saturday night
at 5 00 p.m no like 6 p.m
and reset exactly the same chemistry
exam
like in a classroom on campus on
saturday night
and wow when i redid the exam i got 37
percent
you found an extra 12 on there i know
but i'm pretty sure i had the i had the
exam
to study like i had all the answers
that is um i took the sat
twice because i wanted to improve my
math score i had done like really well
on like the verbal and the reading but
my math score was like not good
and when i took it the second time i got
the exact same score again
oh wow and so i just kind of was like
you know what
this is how good at math is yeah this is
just we've tried twice
and i'm this good yeah it's the perfect
you know like gauge you are no better
than that at math it doesn't matter how
hard you try that's all you got
i did i studied between tests i tried
i am not going to be better than this
at math um okay so as i'm getting this
like picture of your school
i'm wondering because to me like so
you're
you know you're in new zealand you're
looking at american school being like
i wish that i could be having a food
fight or whatever
yeah yeah but to me
like what you're describing seems truly
so exotic so
harry pottery and mysterious to me yeah
what was like the because i also
imagined like
all these traditions and like rowdiness
like yeah yeah how much were you hazing
each other like what was all that
there's it's i think it was
another point of private school like
christchurch is meant to
um be the most british
you know the most english city in new
zealand
it's where the first settlers arrived
and you know it's
in my in my lifetime and also i guess in
the in the
the social circles that i have like it's
been incredible to watch this entire
notion of how this is a very respectable
and fantastic thing being dismantled in
real time so like
you know growing up i was like this is
amazing we're so british in all this and
then it's like i know this is not
a desirable you know thing at all but it
was
yeah there was like it was mod it's
modeled on english
uh like a i think a very famous only
school called eaton which is like a very
very
elite kind of it's where all of the um
the tory prime ministers went to school
and stuff and i've heard of it and it
also
you're also if you've ever seen the
movie dead poets society
yes like i'm picturing dead poets since
i was
not with new zealand accents yes i've
always asked people what
flavor of high school did you go to and
i think your flavor of high school
is dead poet's society this is like a
harry potter spring yeah
the buildings are like old stone
buildings so it is
it's an overlay of those two but
everyone has new zealand accents
which makes it so much more fun yeah
yeah why i think
to listen to it makes it sound like it's
of no consequence
but um yeah so it was always hazing but
it was
always done
you know under under the idea that it's
so much better now than it was
like you know no matter what you're
going through it's like yeah but you're
lucky you weren't here two years ago
when they'd
shove you in a wheelie bin and push you
down the stairs or whatever and you and
so
while you're being pushed into a
stationary rubbish bin in the locker
room you'd be like well you're right i
am
tremendously grateful for this
experience yeah like
you you don't even this this this thing
could be moving
yeah you're right i'm drowning in banana
peels and gratitude george thank you so
much
but so there was always there and what
it does do is it instills in you
because you're so young and malleable
the idea that as you
as you advance through the school years
that you owe
the same sort of like needless bullying
to the people who come through beneath
you
but the the ways in which that my
friends and i in courthouse would try
and
apply this was less like um
less sort of just blindly brutish and
abiding the idea of hazing and more like
you know we want to try and
have a bit have a bit of fun with it
let's just like openly crawl
for no reason yeah yeah but
you know certainly by no means perfect
but like
a lot of it would come out at the house
master so there was this really we had a
every house has a house master professor
mcgonagall styles
of course i know the rules yeah
yeah you get it this guy called his
nickname was gel
because um because he had a
he had a proclivity he'd give out jelly
beans for good behavior or
pupils he liked which is um sus
yeah something honestly there's
something weird about it when
it's all you little boys and you've got
your little outfits on and he's handing
you jelly beans
there's something weird about it this is
super weird about and he was the he was
the classics teacher and the latin
teacher so if you do classics
he'd love like playing caligula you know
he'd love playing caligula for this room
full of 16 or 17 year old boys be like
yeah
drink it in and if you were naughty in
his classroom you had to go and run a
lap around a
sports field was called upper named
after a war hero
charles apple and you had to go and run
around
the upper and like everyone could watch
you run around the
you know there was no consequence but we
would like
he was a an odd dude and
he was also he would try to be very
strict
and he um i think this meant that there
was a lot of pushback from our group
that was where we would channel like the
hazing energy it was like you know we'd
miss her
like with the kids who are yeah below us
would sort of like
you know you you i guess you'd be mean
to them
not in a not just you're still trying to
be funny
and you want like everyone to appreciate
the part of it is funny but you're not
being a legend
but like he would every day walk into
the house and there'd be a white board
like in front of his office that would
say
at the top of it it always said see me
and then there'd be a list of boys
written in cursive just their surname
and like you know going back to the
giving and trouble thing if you saw see
me
montgomery you'd be like oh oh [ __ ] you
know yeah that's like i'm in a lot of
trouble
yeah he found out i was i remember what
i was pulled moon i was mooning some
some fellow pupils out the window but
like the where the house was it looked
out onto
a busy christchurch street obviously
showing your ass cheeks to the the
general public when you're fully over
the school
is not desirable and i realize now that
the reason that they were so precious
about predict
protecting like the traditions and the
reputation is because
everyone who is not inside of this
hallowed bubble of a high school
[ __ ] hated us and rightly so because
we're these like
private school boy terrors who are just
have no
consequence like they have no
understanding of what the real world is
or you know notion of consequence we're
just these
yeah so would you like to shouts would
it be like
you guys would all show up and you'd be
like it's town day and then you guys
just like descend on a town or
yeah yeah not not in town but like yeah
like you you'd have to go through school
and you you know in uniform and we'd
wear these penguin stripe blazers and
like
it was it was crazy when you're at high
school it's like
there are two different and some of you
get to wear shorts and there's one
uniform but like
i think it's like on monday and tuesday
you have to wear your suits which is
like grey suits with long pants and a
jacket
and like a round collared shirt and then
on the other days you'd wear
your sports uniform which is like the
penguin stripe blazer and a pointy
collared white shirt and you could wear
pants or shorts
it's just it's so absurd and so you go
out and you know you'd stick out
like a sore thumb as you go out to
christchurch whatever and you're all
wearing these uniforms and like you know
i think you just get a reputation around
this yeah yeah and freely and people
like
people don't there's a people don't like
you
and that's fine but there's a crosstown
rivals were a school called christchurch
boys high school
and that was like the the large public
school equipment like it's the same
you're getting the same schooling
experience but
um you're not paying through the nose
for it essentially and it's all zoned so
you have to be living in a certain
you know diametrical area to go to the
school
and i remember once i was biking home in
my penguin straight blazer
and they were like i got uh i could feel
this dirt
or like something really hard that
turned out to be like a firm dirt club
like strike my back
i was like oh [ __ ] and then i could feel
one hit my tongue i was like oh no
i start biking fast and then dirt climbs
coming the front as well
and i like tried to get away but i could
there were sort of five
boys high guys around and i was like oh
no it's on now
and um stopped my bike and they're all
around me and i was like oh i'm about to
get like my first
pure beat down like these guys are gonna
actually yeah
lay hands on me and then they just what
what this such door grommet walks up to
me
and he's like what do you like better
ford or holden which are two car brands
and i was like i don't really know or
care about cars and i was like um
hold them and then the leader the guy
asked me the question goes to his friend
see i [ __ ] told you so and that was
all they wanted from me
and i just i i biked away was there any
significance to that question that you
could
like is there is there some new zealand
cultural thing i'm not
no no it's i think it's mostly just
strangers just for different
like you know cliques or whatever and at
the high school
there were different guiding principles
for what you know you derive social
value from and i guess
there was a lot of tribalism among
certain pockets of the student body for
people who liked
fords and people who liked holden and
they wanted to bring in
an outsider and did they have a little
outfit too
they did have a little outfit too they
would wear like a black blazer with blue
like a royal blue trim
and you know the the where that happened
was a place called hagley park which is
like huge expensive
um park in the middle of christchurch
that would like sit you know that was
essentially in the middle of the two
school grounds christ college on one
side and boys high on the other side and
they were like
every year we we try and compete with
them at sports every year we'd have like
our big first 15 which is like the best
rugby team from our school would play
their best rugby team
and every year they would absolutely
[ __ ] tell us by like 50 points
and just get absolutely reamed by these
guys and you know
everyone shop and be like this is our
year and then we just get punished
and it was um oh like unless you're in
the team or
you know you decide that that is what
your identity is as a pupil you don't
really
you don't really care the muscley is
yeah but also it's like well
what do i care about what you think
because you just got beaten by 15
muslier kids
from across the park so did you
have was there like an all girls school
that you yeah yeah yeah like mostly
affiliated with
there were two there were sort of two
okay i
and we'd like if we do school like we do
drama productions or whatever
we'd alternate years with the girls
school who would perform the worst oh
oh my god if i hit see if i had heard
that as a teenager i don't think i ever
would have thought of a more romantic
thing
than like yeah meeting the boys school
to do a play
i know but i i i thought the same thing
but i didn't know that everyone was
experiencing the same wave of nerves
about like
meeting girls or boys or whatever as i
was and so i
i never had the like i know i always be
funny and cool but i was i never had the
self-confidence to actually
secure myself a girlfriend i would make
friends
but i like every time i'd be like oh my
god the school production i can't wait
to fall in love
and then i'd sort of play the role of
like you know funny third or fourth
friend
in the wings like chiming in with the
joke but yeah
there were two like equivalent schools
one was called saint margaret's one was
called
rangiduru and they're like nearby
and did they have like did i i always
ask this
about like private schools but did they
have like different reputations
like oh the saint margaret's girls yeah
yeah wifey or
whatever yeah they did i can't remember
what they are
but i'm certain that it would have been
like you know yeah it would be
it would be something like you practice
on the saint margaret's girls and you
marry the
you know or the other way around yeah
some horrific
you know based notion that some of them
are
good for having sex with and some of
them are good for making your wives
yeah i mean that was going on that was
going on among public middle schools
when i was growing up and my middle
school
middle school by the way which is like
11 and 12 year olds was the [ __ ] one
that had
herpes which is like no one's incredible
yeah yeah what what is this based on
what is this based on it so yeah it gets
worse
from from like because going across
college obviously you had those
perceptions of the
private girls schools and then you'd be
even more derogatory to the public girls
schools
because it's classism and so you'd be
like ah and then there's
and then there are these guys and you
really got to watch out for them you
know
it's like no i'd like you because word
of your middle school made it to our
school and like it's a bit like that one
where they've all got herpes
exactly we lived in constant fear of
trans-atlantic herpes from these middle
schoolers
my middle school was obsessed with
herpes probably because we had this
reputation
but i don't think that anyone really had
herpes or if they did it was just like
the mouth kind that they had since they
were born or whatever like i don't
yeah i don't think like my middle school
we were thinking about herpes often
and i don't think was that under adult
supervision or were you just running
wild with your own ideas of herpes
um i mean i think it was i think it was
brought on a little bit
by like sex panic in general
because this was around the time i don't
know if you guys
dealt with this but where the news
thought that everybody was trading
bracelets
okay [ __ ] me bracelets yeah okay
okay cool i wasn't sure where did that
travel
again you take out the blue bit from the
coke bottle and you'd peel out the
middle and you'd stretch out
the bracelet did you so we did those but
there were also just these rubber
bracelets and they came in different
colors and
the news told everybody's parents that
the bracelet colors
messed up corresponded to sexual
activity
and so there was a lot of stuff around
there there was a rumor that girls were
gonna wear different colored lipsticks
at parties and give [ __ ] to
guys who like their penis would then
have rings around it which actually
doesn't even work
i know but i i heard all this stuff too
and because it's all like sort of coming
in from america
it is my belief that we exported a lot
of moral panic
and like weird stuff
but there was no skepticism that this
was true i was like god damn
all the 14 year old guys in america are
getting their dick sucked with 12
different colors of lipstick
yeah i'm just figuring out how to
masturbate you know like i gotta keep up
these kids in america are having parties
where they're just
bl the whole party is just blowing each
other
that was not i assure you that was not
what was happening
because that was just something our
adults made up about
us which is a different kind of weird
[Laughter]
uh okay let's actually take a look at
the
photos that you sent now i feel like
this is the perfect
time to round out the picture of teen
guy
okay how old are we here so i'm
this is preteen i'm guessing
by the sort of slightly disproportionate
face
almost like alfred newman here yeah you
do
you really do i was probably 11
here uh are we in the uniform so we're
in the
we're in the um cathedral grammy uniform
which is like a school that is
almost a feeder school for um for christ
college so cathedral grammar is like
i was there from five to uh
12 or 13 and it was all you know years
one two and three are
co-educational so it was mixed classes
and then from then on it's just
for the fellas and uh
yeah so that guy there he's all right i
was actually very i was very athletic
until puberty and then um everyone's
bodies
started giving them unfair advantages
and i i couldn't be bothered applying
myself and so i sort of fell out of love
with sports but that guy
that guy was pretty close to rocking out
like i think i was probably rocking out
the hardest at that point until
you know i sort of secured my identity
and self-confidence as an adult
that guy's doing pretty good yeah so
like
what are this guy's like top three
like the top three loves in this
version of guy's life are what uh
keenan and kell used to love coming home
from school to watch
like cannon cow's the first show i
remember watching and laughing out loud
by myself
so loves cute and cow loves playing
touch rugby
with the boys
so you know that's like rugby union but
without tackling
i was never big on tackling i didn't
like getting hurt but i could use my
my gas and acceleration and uh
my third live i mean
what do you like there you just i just
like i like going ski
skiing like i just like i just liked
were you like a video game
kid wasn't allowed wasn't allowed to
watch tv it wasn't a loud video game
console
um i like destiny's child at that point
i remember
yeah yeah um but i was
i i what i really wanted was
eyebrows and uh
to kiss a girl and neither of those were
forthcoming
at what point would you kiss a girl
last uh end of third form so end of
year nine i don't know what grade that
is but first year of high school
at the last school dance i kissed a girl
who was a head shorter than me
i didn't know where i didn't know how to
do it i had my eyes open
it was like looking around the room i
was kissing her which is very stressful
and creepy
and a guy who was cooler than me who had
been kissing girls for years
it was like an old family friend but
sort of was bounding up the social
ladder
much quicker than i could hope to saw me
with my eyes open and pogged me in the
eye
oh my god and this girl was no one to
you she was just who you were with at
the end of the dance and
the kissing moment landed and yeah i
know her name
but um oh yeah i i'm not going to say it
and i do not know
anything about her as an adult because
it was like
almost 20 years ago [ __ ]
crazy were you at a point where you were
feeling the pressure to kiss and so you
were just kind
of like i gotta get a kiss like this
happen well i yeah like we all know the
rules in
in high school right which is if you
don't have sex in high school
then you don't get to have sex at all
yeah you never
will so you got it you got to take care
of your business
and um you know there's a huge amount of
social pressure and the people you
surround yourself with are all
you know going through their paces at
different stages and you're just
thinking
i gotta get i gotta get some runs on the
board here yeah
so did you have any like long-term
girlfriends in high school no not really
i didn't no not even any uh short-term
short-term girlfriends i had uh
like you know i had girls who i was
friends with
and who i liked and who with hindsight
liked me back but i did neither of us
had the or i didn't have the courage
where you know these these are fairly
conservative schools
so it was on me to take initiative and i
um
i never did it's so there are so many
things like times where
i would just go back and tell my team
self and the teen self of
everyone i've talked to like of course
they have a crush on you you all have a
crush on each other
yeah yeah each other out you are like no
but
there's no greater humiliation than
thinking they might
then finding out they don't you'll never
you will never recover from that
no and everyone will know that's right
why everyone is thinking about it just
as much as you
100 like it would
were you a big unrequited
love person uh
no like no oh i guess in
in flashes but it sort of mellowed with
time and i was like well
eventually by the end of high school i
was like well
you know christchurch by new zealand
center is a big enough city by the end
of high school
well i guess the thing is you gotta get
out of christchurch
[Laughter]
uh all right let's take a look at this
next photo
all right who do we have here so
i i certainly don't have permission to
to share that photo that would be
a guy called toby pisey
uh he was a boarder cooler more athletic
one of the he rode and he played rugby
and you can see he's pretty switched on
he's got a jacket and a rose
yeah there in the
white and blue stripe shirt button-down
shirt with a print t-shirt underneath it
and a very
very loose fitting pair of huffa
trousers
young montgomery i believe on the way to
the
fifth form dance or semi-formal
and you'll see i've embraced the idea of
semi-formal
you know is shiny i'm gonna
yeah yeah wow translucent yeah
well at least it was it was the style at
the time i
and yeah so i i went to this dance i'm
with a friend i actually don't know
which friend i took but like with a
friend who was a girl
who almost definitely wound up making
out with someone else
and um these were not the dancers were
not
they weren't terrible for me that was
fine but they also weren't like i didn't
look forward to them in the ways that
uh other kids did because i was like i
was like oh
man it's just a whole night of me
experiencing the pressure of hooking up
with someone and not pulling it off
yeah it like there were times when it
was like the dance is like a social
obligation
that you have to fulfill like it's like
okay
i'm going to the company holiday party
for like an hour
whatever exactly and that little that
little dweeb there
he's got about 10 pubes to his name and
just needs a clip around the air and to
be told
just figure yourself out mate you'll be
fine
you are embodying you mention you
mentioned this briefly but you are
embodying the
like early teen boy style of just
enormous pants yeah yeah that don't fit
at all
i know for about three years and then
it's very important that the pants cling
to your legs
like you know what is it about a 12 year
old boy an enormous pants
what what comfort does it provide i
guess
what it probably is is that there was a
14 year old boy in enormous pens who was
an older brother of one of the 12 year
old boys and they're like well this is
what the 14 year old's wearing and
you're like
yeah i know mom
we've got to get down to shops and buy
the most wide leg pair of trousers
available
at least they'll be ostracized
exactly yeah i don't know
they you just gotta wear the big pants
you gotta wear this
you gotta wear the print t-shirt you
gotta have the shiny over [ __ ] you gotta
do it
giant pants as formal wear is something
that has
come up on this podcast across ages
across the country now across
you know the globe so they're really
there is
there is a sacred bond between pre-teen
boys and and giant pants that we've been
this podcast is ultimately an
exploration eye yeah you love to hear it
all right let's take a look at this next
photo so
okay who do we have here we got a guy
who's feeling himself
a little more yeah and so
this was like the last holiday that some
friends and i took before
um leaving high school i believe we're
in wanaka
here which is like a mountain town in
the south island
and um what have we got on we've got the
fake gucci shades
baby we've got uh hats that i would
actually still love toying to this day
that a friend brought back from a
holiday
in japan it had like this cool bear logo
on the front
we've got like a sort of novelty humor
t-shirt or like an
it's an old ad for wheat books which
like our version of wheaties i guess
and um you'll see on my friend there
andrew
a lot of the other guys have gotten into
straightening their hair at this point
oh wow i don't think i thankfully
sidestepped
but uh this guy is
like he's got good friends and he's
pretty heavy and he's
he's made out with a few girls now but
he's also um
he's also a massive virgin and he
carries that around his neck like a
you know like a [ __ ] tombstone and uh
so he's sort of he's just he's living in
abject fear
that his his dick will go untouched for
time and memorial
and that like the amount you are running
out of time
actively to ever yeah yeah yeah
yes and so you know there are still
moments of my day and my week where i
can enjoy life but this
is the dominating thought and force in
my life
absolutely so was this like did you guys
have uh because in the u.s we have like
beach week
after senior year sometimes where
everyone like goes to the beach and you
have like
you act rowdy was that kind of what this
was uh
not quite no yeah i mean not this trip
but there is sort of an equivalent
there's so
like new year's eve because our summer
falls at the end of the school year
right over christmas and new year's like
everyone sort of
you you you latch on to your clan and
everyone
goes away to some you know some place
where a parent might have a holiday
house or whatever
uh for new year's and that's where
everyone sort of gets boozy and peers
off and
sort of satiates their their outstanding
uh desires from high school you know
i know no but not me no actually this
new year's
i um i got hammer drunk like blackout
drunk
lost all my friends and pretended to be
a south african tourist
for the night wow to
and did you pass or was everyone like uh
i know i probably what's wrong with this
guy from my memory i passed but they're
also
like what's wrong with this guy i don't
know what i was thinking i mean
it was outside the box i guess it was
like some form of escapism
when did you first start drinking and
were you and your friends getting like
very drunk i was i was uh pretty slow
off the mark
but i guess by new zealand standards
anyway 16
and i used to drink i didn't like i
carbonated beverages at all
i didn't like um i used to when i was a
kid i didn't like it and i was
never had the bravery to try the media i
thought that the bubbles were like
little knives
on my tongue and that's what i would say
and so
i would drink these drinks called um
vodka mud shakes which are like
it's like vodka and chocolate milk i
guess pre-mix and it is um
it's not good it was like you know it
was like drinking chocolate milk at the
time and that's
that's pretty much what you wanted the
satisfaction of drinking chocolate milk
with the knowledge you will become drunk
okay that is such an insane
drink were you the only person drinking
that or was that like a common drink for
others
some of the nah nah some of the gals
were putting back a few mudshakes
most of the fellas were drinking beer
and then i also drink like um
you know like a pre-mixed vodka orange
which is
like okay see that's good me
i just feel like when me and my friends
started drinking which was also around
we just would drink the like there was
no thought about like actually having an
enjoyable experience or enjoying the
drink it was just all about
like getting yeah completely [ __ ]
drunk
yeah it becomes that you sort of you you
put the gas down as time goes on
to the point that you're like you know
there's a year or so there where you're
like the entire point is to wipe your
memory of what's happening which is
just patently i just you know like
there's a few things i'd like to shake
myself
as a as a teenager to be like man
this is not it the years from high
school to um
probably you know until like 21 or 22
maybe 23.
i feel like i didn't make a single
decision like i did not
i was not an active participant in
decision making in my life like you know
i would go with the largest group of
friends were going in a way that would
ensure like i could socially blend or
like blend in as best as i could
i did not feel like i was in charge and
yeah
getting black out drunk was as as a
party to that which is just like well
this is what everyone else around you is
doing it's not fun if you're not doing
it so you might as well do it
yeah and it's like and find something
you enjoy but
you're really not in charge now like
you really don't have to be thinking
about anything that you're doing
at this moment exactly all right i think
we've got
one more photo here all right
i'm seeing some of the billabong style
that's happening here
pants are a little smaller well they're
shorts
so these shorts are a little bit even
stiff yeah they're still they're still a
wide leg
volcan cargo short that's gonna reach
over the knee
and we've got six pockets to put in that
one
tiny little nokia cell phone uh this is
actually
we are now at the start of university
and uh we uh at this point now we've got
a new group of people
from whom one of the sole objectives is
to mask the fact
i am a virgin uh that is tremendously
important in fact the first time
i had sex i before i even
had sex i was in a in the hostel room
with one of the
the girls or the girl to whom it would
have to to whom i would have sex with at
university
and uh i would have sex upon yeah yeah
well that was the goal but i realized
that we were going to have sex
and the fear of god and the enthusiasm
of my ejaculate got the better of me and
i came in my trousers
before anything could happen and instead
of just
and instead of being like hey i'm a
virgin or hey i just came in my pants
i've said hey i just remembered my
friend
is on a gap year in wales and i
scheduled to skype him
in 10 minutes you know i got to get out
of here
and i left wow
what did i do i'm so glad you asked i
went to a bathroom
i changed my underpants i removed any
extra hecks of chisholm and i returned
to the room
to have sex which lasted all of 15
seconds
and only after that experience was she
was like are you okay and i was like ah
that was my first time
and she's like you should have said so
you know she's like looking back some
clues were there but you really should
have told me
um yeah it's so fun what's funny to me
about that story apart from literally
all of the details of it
is that i'm sure that you were so
convinced the entire time one that like
you're the only virgin at university
number two that you're the only man
anything
resembling this has ever happened to
when in fact
tail as old as time ah 100
but you know you don't yeah it was just
holy hell so yeah again that like i
i was having a good time but also
you know i did not relieve any of this
uh sexual anxiety
for for a year like years after this
really
it's just so interesting because all of
us go into
the puberty time like so in the dark and
it's so
easy to get so many harmful
messages like for you to come out of
high school thinking that it is like
an extreme anomaly for you to have not
have
had sex when it's like very common
but it's because it's also an old boys
school and like all of your friends
there's all this like bravado and what
happens it's like
um i didn't really have the
security of communicating that anxiety
so you just you just carry it around
with you and you know it enhances in
fact i mean i
i don't know there's been brought up on
the podcast before but one of the
things like i have enjoyed watching big
mouth so much as an adult
and being like this this is like a bible
that high school pupils should watch
that articulates that everyone is going
through some excruciating version
of what you're going through and it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
was no text to which i could refer to
put my mind at these it was just like me
and my thoughts being like oh man you
are done
no and the sex ed you do get is like
just a scientific
non-emotional thing or i don't even what
sex ed did you get
my parents left a book called where do i
come from on the kitchen table one
morning when neither of them were around
amazing so you didn't do any in school
no we do we had a health instructor
called mr pike
but i feel like my main memories of that
is
um in one class one of the pupils asked
if dinosaurs could be gay and he didn't
have an answer
okay and in another class he'd obviously
just finished reading the secret
and he kept telling everyone that you
can do anything you put your mind to
and we'd be like well what if i want to
be the fastest runner in the world
and he'd say well you could be and we'd
be like but i'm not
and he'd be like because you don't
believe it and we'd be like
[ __ ] off mr pike this is ridiculous
also you're like why are we here
also can a dinosaur be gay is the most
like boy's school sex ed question
like absolutely hey can a dinosaur
like okay congratulations
i feel like somewhere every year
somewhere a 12 year old boy asks okay
and i'll tell you this they absolutely
crush
like oh every time
it gets a big laugh oh if someone had
said can a dinosaur be gay in my sex ed
class
oh they would have they would have
slayed it
yeah it came over all right i think
we're coming to the end here
so uh as our very last question
if you could tell teen guy
anything what would you tell him
uh i just say do like
i don't know man follow your instincts
and do what you enjoy like
you gotta stop living in the um
in the fear or in the shadow of like
other people what other people think of
you which is such a
you know it's such a hokey cliche thing
but it's like i feel like it's the thing
that every teenager needs to hear is
like
you're living your life and no one else
cares about it like you do
so stop stop making every decision
you know underneath the notion of what
other people will think of it
and just do it for yourself 100
i mean i need to remind myself that all
the time now i have to be like
you're not the star of the movie in
everyone's head like people no
i know i'm always thinking about you
well guys this was an amazing episode
thank you so much
for joining me thank you for having me
yes you expanded the roasts universe
by yeah so i'm so excited
and for everyone listening at home this
has been the roast of your teenage self
[Music]
podcast
you